[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur ces dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous en
interprétation de plus en plus
d'articles et de reportages s'intéresse
à l'océan arctique raisons économiques
et militaires
centré autour du pôle nord cette partie
du monde concernent prioritairement les
membres du conseil de l'arctique qui
regroupe tous les pays riverains de
l'océan du même nom l'islande la norvège
la suède la finlande la russie l'alaska
américain
le canada et le groenland créée en 1996
par la déclaration d'ottawa ce conseil à
vocation de favoriser la coopération la
coordination et l'interaction entre les
états de l'arctique et n'est pas saisie
des questions intéressant la sécurité
militaire
on peut y ajouter bien que cela ne soit
pas spécifié qu'il s'agit d'empêcher les
autres pays non arctiques
à commencer par la chine et l'inde de
participer à l'exploitation de la zone
à l'époque de la guerre froide
l'arctique était une zone intermédiaire
stratégique entre le bloc soviétique et
le bloc occidental
d'où l'on pouvait détecter ce qui se
passait d'un côté et de l'autre des
lancements de missiles aux interceptions
de communications et ceci justifiait
l'installation de stations d'écouté et
de détection ainsi que de nombreux vols
de reconnaissance et de surveillance par
les deux parties en présence
les tensions existantes entre les
américains et les russes depuis 15 ans
on relançait ses actions militaires dans
cette vaste zone inhospitalière qui
revêt une importance stratégique
croissante plus rapide qu'ailleurs le
réchauffement climatique provoquant la
fonte de la banquise du permafrost
sibérien ou canadien et de la calotte
glaciaire du groenland a ajouté de
nouvelles dimensions qui excite les
convoitises sur les routes maritimes les
gisements de gaz et de pétrole
les nodules métalliques et les mines de
terres rares lors des siècles précédents
l'accès à l'arctique été rendues très
difficiles par une glaciation quasi
permanente
le passage du nord-ouest qui part de la
baie d'hudson longe la côte du canada
continue entre les îles arctiques du
nord canadien traverse la mer de
beaufort
avant d'arriver au détroit de béring
entre l'alaska et la russie n'ait été
franchi victorieusement qu'en 1906 par
roald amundsen après quatre siècles de
dizaines de tentatives infructueuses et
malheureusement souvent mortelle pour
les explorateurs
on a d'ailleurs longtemps cru que le
pôle nord avait été découvert par
l'américain péri en 1909
mais les historiens selon numéro 2 132
la revue l'histoire s'accordent à dire
qu'en réalité
ce fut fait beaucoup plus tard en avril
1948 par une équipe soviétique l'autre
passage et celui du nord-est qui longe
la nouvelle zemble la russie européenne
et la sibérie pour déboucher dans
l'océan pacifique au détroit de berry
celui ci a été franchi pour la première
fois par nordine scholes en 1879 puis
par un moune scène en 1920 avec chaque
fois un hivernage bloqués par les glaces
le réchauffement climatique a rendu ses
deux passages libre de glace une partie
de l'année est franchissable en hiver
avec l'aide de brise glaces ce qui offre
des opportunités très intéressantes pour
le commerce maritime car il réduit la
longueur des routes entre l'asie et
l'europe
c'est ainsi que la distance entre
rotterdam et shanghai par le passage du
nord ouest et de 16 mille 900 km et par
le passage du nord-est de 15000 100 km
contre 25 mille quatre cents par le
canal de panama et 19 1700 par le canal
de suez avec un gain de temps de l'ordre
de 30 à 40 %
comme le signale l'observatoire de
l'arctique
les avantages sont une réduction des
délais de transport qui s'accompagne
d'une réduction des coûts mais aussi une
forte diminution des primes d'assurance
puisqu'il n'y a plus de risque de
piraterie en mer de chine du sud vers
malacca et dans l'océan indien
enfin il n'ya pas taxe est payée comme
pour le passage du canal de suez
l'économie est donc considérable on peut
ajouter que le passage du nord-est
bénéficie de 25 ports aménagés dont neuf
ouvert toute l'année au long du parcours
et n'entraîne pas de problème de tirant
d'eau et de largeur contrairement à
celui du nord-ouest le potentiel de gain
économique sur le transport est donc
énorme entre les marchés asiatiques et
européens
de ce fait on estime que 15 % du trafic
maritime mondial va transiter par les
passages ceci explique pour partie
l'opposition dans l'arctique entre les
etats-unis et la russie et à un moindre
niveau le canada qui se réfère à la
convention de montego bay dont j'ai
parlé dans mon émission haute tension en
mer de chine qui fixe les règles de la
souveraineté maritime et des conditions
d'exploitation de la
depuis sa mise en oeuvre en 1994 elle a
été signée par 150 cet état sans les
états unis bien sûr qui font pourtant
référence pour réclamer la libre
circulation de leurs navires militaires
en dehors des eaux strictement
territoriales or la convention reconnaît
que les zones correspondant
approximativement au plateau continental
et s'étendant sur 200 miles nautiques
sont ce qu'on appelle des aides des
zones économiques exclusives des pays
riverains en application de cette
convention le gouvernement canadien
considère le passage du nord-ouest comme
faisant partie des eaux intérieures du
canada ce que les usa et la france
conteste le considérant comme un détroit
international avec libre passage
et ceci a provoqué plusieurs incidents
sérieux depuis le franchissement sans
autorisation du pétrolier manhattan en
1969 puis du brise-glace militaire polar
si en 1985
un nouvel incident en 2005 a révélé que
les sous-marins nucléaires us utiliser
cette route régulièrement en réalité
comme l'avait expliqué louis bellemare
dans le blog libre échange de
l'association des économistes québécois
en 2018
le canada est confronté à trois
possibilités ne rien faire
ce qui rend difficile la défense de ces
droits de passage investir très
lourdement pour rendre le passage
concurrentiel par rapport à celui du
nord-est et pouvoir défendre ses droits
légitimes
ce qui lui fait prendre un vrai risque
économique ou bien encore négocier une
alliance avec les etats-unis et d'autres
partenaires auxquels on demandera une
contrepartie du droit de passage à
travers une contribution importante à
l'investissement requis
à l'heure actuelle rien n'a été décidé
d'autant que les américains n'ayant pas
vu venir les nouvelles ou route maritime
du nord n'ont fait aucun investissement
lourd en alaska
depuis les années 70
du côté russe la situation est
totalement différente
depuis les années 2000 l'état considère
que le développement de l'arctique est
vital pour la russie le président
medvedev
n'ayant pas hésité en 2008 a précisé
qu'il fallait faire de l'arctique la
base de ressources de la russie pour le
28 ème siècle à l'heure actuelle il
représente déjà 10% du produit intérieur
brut de la fédération de russie et 20%
des exportations en dans ce cadre
l'aménagement du passage du nord-est est
un projet prioritaire qui s'appuie non
seulement sur le transit international
asie europe mais aussi sur le transport
des énergies fossiles et des minerais
issus de la zone
d'autant que la chine a signé avec la
russie un contrat d'utilisation du
passage en complément des routes de la
soie qui devrait s'appuyer sur la mise à
disposition d'une partie de leur brise
glace bien que soumise aux incertitudes
de la navigation polaire l'augmentation
du tonnage transitant par la route
maritime nord et spectaculaire d'un
niveau légèrement supérieur à un demi
million de tonnes en 2013
selon l' annonce du président poutine en
2014 au conseil de sécurité
il est passé à 5 millions en 2020 et
devrait atteindre 20 millions de tonnes
d'ici 2025
nous n'en sommes qu'au début puisqu'on
compte pour le moment moins de 100
transit complet parents d'évolution
climatique laisse prévoir que le sait en
arctique sera totalement libre de glace
est ouvert la navigation vers 2040 2050
au delà de l'apparence vertueuse de la
coopération justifiée par la défense des
aspects environnementaux économiques et
sociaux du développement durable dans
cette région
évolutive il est clair qu'il existe des
approches plus intéressé
une étude de l'institut de géophysique
américain de 2008 estime le potentiel
des fonds sous-marins de l'arctique à 13
% de la ressource mondiale de pétrole et
à 30% de celles du gaz naturel
essentiellement en alaska et en russie
du coup comme l'expliquent challenges.fr
dans son édition du 17 mars le cercle de
l'arctique s'est ouvert aux
revendications territoriales
ottawa oslo et copenhague ont demandé
l'extension de leur plateau continental
au delà de leurs zones économiques
exclusives 200 milles marins ce qui leur
ouvrirait des droits sur et sous les
fonds marins
il est vrai que la norvège dont une
grosse partie de l'économie dépend du
pétrole estiment que la mer de barents
possède plus de 60% des réserves
pétrolières non exploitées du pays
elle veut aussi débuté en 2023
l'exploitation minière de son plateau
continental qui contient du zinc du
cobalt de l'or de l'argent et surtout de
l'ordre de 6 9 millions de tonnes de
cuivre
le président trump envisagé de faire de
même pour l'alaska
bien que ce soit une zone naturelle
protégée et que les états unis n'est pas
ratifié la convention de montego bay le
président biden a tout bloqué car
ceux-ci il plaçait en contradiction avec
sa propre argumentation diplomatique
envers la chine le canada et la russie
cette dernière qui considèrent
stratégique le développement de ses
ressources naturelles prétend que ses
limites territoriales s'étendent sous
l'océan arctique le long des dorsales
qu'on appelle lomonosov et mendeleïev
qui sont des extensions son plateau
continental
et ceci lui permet de revendiquer une
superficie de 1,2
millions de kilomètres carrés
supplémentaires de la région dont le
pôle nord tout ceci bien sûr au
détriment du canada et du danemark
la chine a compris très tôt que les
passage du nord-ouest et du nord-est
pouvait devenir des routes maritimes
vers l'europe plus intéressante que
celle du sud et que le réchauffement en
arctique
ouvrez d'énormes possibilités minière
c'est pourquoi à côté des causes
investissements avec la russie sur la
cause sibérienne elle s'intéresse de
très près à l'islande et surtout au
groenland ce territoire autonome danois
regorge de possibilités minière et
dispose d'une des plus importantes
réserves de terres rares au monde
en plus de la protection de ses intérêts
vitaux de défense
ceci explique pourquoi le président
entre hommes souvenez vous voulez
racheté cette île immense en 2019 la
chine voulant préserver son quasi
monopole de fait sur les 17 métaux
concernés veut s'impliquer dans la
recherche et l'exploitation en aidant
financièrement ce territoire peuplé de
55 mille habitants qui n'a pas les
moyens d'exploiter ses richesses et
manquent de port moderne et de brise
glaces ouvrir des routes
notons à l'instar de damien de georges
dans son excellent livre sur les terres
rares qui s'y aussi la france et c'est
tirer quelque avantage autour et sur le
groënland plus la glace fond et plus les
appétits grossistes le secrétaire d'état
américain anthony blinken a accusé la
russie d'avoir fait des réclamations
maritimes illégales sur la
réglementation des navires étrangers
transitant par la route maritime nord on
retrouve ici l'argument développé par
les français au sujet de la mer de chine
demandant la libre circulation des
navires militaires
au delà des eaux territoriales ce qui a
déjà été refusée par le canada pour
l'autre passage on peut ajouter goût
washington
occupée par la militarisation croissante
de la région appelait à ne pas
militariser l'arctique au nom de la
liberté de circulation
sachant que la route du nord-est sera la
plus fréquentée les etats unis
s'inquiètent du risque de blocus du
passage en cas de conflit politique et
en réponse sergueï lavrov le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères a rappelé
dans une conférence de presse à
reykjavik le 17 mai qu'une grande partie
de l'arctique fait partie depuis
longtemps de leur territoire ajoutant
qu'il est donc légale et légitime qu'ils
assurent la sécurité de leur littoral et
développe une activité militaire pour la
défendre
pour théo maneval sur europe 1 le 19 mai
consciente des enjeux la russie met en
garde l'occident contre des ambitions
illégitime dans la zone il est clair
qu'au delà de la route maritime
la fonte des glaces ouvre l'accès à
d'énormes possibilités pour la pêche et
dans la zone proche de la côte à des
gisements de tous ordres allant de l'or
aux cuivres et au cobalt ainsi que des
thés rares
s'y ajoutent des ressources énergétiques
dont celle existant sur la presqu'île de
yamal et dans la mer de kara
les russes accompagné des français total
pour 20% et des chinois pour 30 %
viennent d'y financer à sa bêta pour 27
milliards de dollars
une énorme usine de liquéfaction de gaz
avec un port et un aéroport dédié à ces
activités il y exploiteront un des trois
premiers gisements gaziers au monde qui
verra sa production transportés par des
méthaniers brise glace
on comprend mieux pourquoi comme le
signale arnaud muller dans son mémoire
de recherche haye afp publié le 25 avril
par diploweb la russie avait définis en
2000 une stratégie pour le grand nord
qui prévoyait de renforcer ses capacités
militaires
en accompagnement du développement de
ses infrastructures
il n'est pas étonnant qu'elle veuille
défendre ce qui va être pour elle un
exceptionnel relais de croissance dans
les 20 ans à venir
depuis les russes ont doublé le nombre
de bases militaires
en remettant en état celle abandonnée
depuis la fin de l'union soviétique
installer des moyens d'interdiction et
déni d'accès créer des unités
spécialisées et organise régulièrement
des exercices
ce qui préoccupe les pays riverains mais
comme le souligne laurent laigneau dans
atlantico du 17 mai les autres pays de
la région membres de l'otan comme la
norvège ou ayant des liens étroits avec
cette organisation ont également
augmenté leurs activités militaires ils
ont réalisé de nombreux exercices dans
cette zone aux conditions extrêmes et
avec de l'aviation de combat des forces
spéciales et des navires militaires
chaque camp explique que c'est en
réponse aux menaces de l'autre les
américains accusent la militarisation
croissante de la zone par la russie les
russes accusent l'otan de mener une
offensive dans l'arctique où elle n'a
aucune raison de venir en utilisant la
norvège comme support opérationnel en
particulier pour des vols de
reconnaissance le long des frontières
une chose est certaine après avoir
abandonné l'océan arctique
après la chute du mur de berlin par
manque d'intérêt stratégique
les grandes puissances si repositionne
à terme elles le font selon geri que
pensait dans le point du 24 novembre
en s'appuyant sur quatre axes les
capacités aéroportée pour la projection
de forces terrestres
dans un environnement particulièrement
difficile avec des températures allant
jusqu'à moins 60 degrés les satellites
dédiés pour observer et anticiper la
concentration en glace et les
installations adverse
les brise glaces pour l'accès aux zones
de surface dont les chinois deviennent
les plus gros constructeurs et enfin les
sous marins nucléaires pour surgir de
n'importe où dans ce cadre
l'exercice a icex de l' us navy réalisés
dans la région tous les deux ans montre
que dans les deux camps
la marine joue un rôle stratégique
essentiel depuis le 4 août 1958 où le
sous marin nucléaire américain nautilus
à naviguer sous la banquise suivi peu de
temps après par l'ufc skate qui émergea
en eau libre tout près du pôle en 1962
le sous marin nucléaire d'attaqué russe
leninski komsomol fut le second à faire
surface au pôle nord
depuis les deux marines ont répété
régulièrement l'exploit
jusqu'au 26 mars de cette année ou trois
sous-marins russes y ont fait surface
dans un rayon de 300 mètres en brisant
1,5 m de glace
cette démonstration de force montre que
ce type de navire capable de naviguer
sous la glace et dans émerger et
parfaitement adapté aux contraintes de
la zone l'évolution de l'arctique
cet endroit où l'eurasie l'amérique du
nord et l'asie pacifique se rencontrent
est en train de devenir un lieu de
tension majeure
dans l'équilibré géopolitique mondiale
comme le constate luc de barochez sedan
le point du 25 mai les européens comme
les américains ont tardé à prendre
conscience des défis économiques et
militaires qui pointe derrière l'enjeu
environnemental
même si christophe de margerie alors
présidente total avait eu le génie
d'investir dans le grand nord sibérien
alors que la france et les occidentaux
n'y croyais pas il faut reconnaître que
l' avance prise par les russes et les
chinois dans l'océan arctique semblent
irrattrapables faisons du pôle nord un
pôle de paix disait mikhaïl gorbatchev
le 1er octobre 1987 à mourmansk
au vu de l'évolution de la situation et
des prises de position des uns et des
autres cela n'en prend pas le chemin et
nous n'en sommes qu'au début
à bientôt
[Musique]